hello and welcome to crosstalk where all
things are considered I'm Peter LaBelle
this is a social distancing edition as
the world continues to grapple with the
coronavirus neoliberalism itself is on
trial what are some of the lessons to be
learned and what needs to change to
crosstalk this and more I'm joined by my
guest to me through Babbage in Moscow
he's the political analyst and editor at
the internet media project they noticed
me in London we have Alexander McCarthy
as a writer on legal affairs an editor
of the neuron calm and in Nicosia we
cross to Alexander Christopher he is a
director and writer for the durán calm
welcome gentlemen to this unique format
this is what we're gonna be using for
the duration of this crisis this global
pandemic and a lot of people are
beginning to take a look at what needs
to be done to get out of this crisis and
a lot of it has to do with money money
and a lot more money and I would like to
pause it to all three of you in this
unique format is that is money the
solution because it seems to me the way
people are talking about money
particularly in the United States in the
European Union is that they want to
spend money to maintain the status quo a
status quo that is very broken Alexander
Mackerras go ahead in London well
firstly pouring money to this problem to
try to deal with a health emergency by
basically cisterna
sustaining the markets looks to me to be
very much like a case of blowing into a
balloon which is already burst
he doesn't seem to me to make a great
deal of economic sense what I gather has
happened is an awful lot of people in
the hedge funds have found themselves
taking very difficult positions which
they've had to clear so they've had to
sell lots and lots of apps assets to
convert them into cash this has created
a major crisis in the markets which is
completely unsurprising so what comes
along invariably in these situations the
Federal Reserve Board and all the other
big central banks they say to themselves
well we've got to step in because if we
don't step in then the whole financial
system will crash
pouring in money then we're basically
creating quite a crash for themselves
it's already crashed for the average
citizen okay it's 2008 all over again
nothing has been Alexander Christopher
let me let me go to you because this is
what really irritates me here I mean I
am NOT again against because of the
circumstances and directly giving aid to
individuals so particularly in small
businesses to keep people on the payroll
keep get things started again because
there is demand except where everything
is frozen up because of this crisis here
but I am very very upset about the idea
of bailing out the very wealthy all over
again it didn't work in 2008 for the
economy overall it helped a certain
strata of society but it didn't help the
average person a lot of those people
lost their houses they couldn't pay
their mortgages and it was a life
determining event for them okay so how
do we go through to make sure that the
people on the ground while saving the
financial sector at the same time it
seems to me that's a quandary I think I
think the main variable here is how long
will this last I think right now we just
don't know in each country has
approached this crisis differently and I
think some countries are handling it a
lot better than others I know where I am
right now the government took a very
quick action and they started closing
everything down and it looks like knock
on wood it looks like we're gonna get
out of this much quicker and say a Spain
Italy France or the UK where the Cyprus
but Cyprus is a country that's very
dependent on tourism correct who wants
to go on yes yes so we're gonna see
we're gonna see how that but once you
once you get past the the health crisis
I think then the government can start
addressing the various sectors of the
economy and how to combat what's
happened to them so in the tourist
sector for example maybe you can start
looking at focusing tourism from within
the country and maybe you know just try
to get people who live inside of a
country to help the tourist market or
whatever that industry may be but I
think that the duration of the health
crisis is going to play a major major
role as to how things will get handled I
will say this Peter its interests
think to see that in the US for example
you're going to have certain sections of
the economy that are going to do well
and would continue to do well if you're
a nurse if you're a doctor if you're
manufacturing masks if you're producing
toilet paper I mean you know take these
industries that are going to do well but
then look at other industries if you're
working in a bar in a restaurant if
you're working in a hair salon a nail
salon these types of industries are
going to get hammered if you're in the
real estate market you're going to get
hammered if you're a landlord you're
going to get hammered so this is could
be a life-changing moment for many many
people and many many countries you know
looking at the mainstream media it's
very interesting to me that instead of
criticizing how the economy has been run
by these elites since 2008 since the
last major crisis which I believe
nothing has really changed it was just
Alexandra cares already used the analogy
was I would use it slightly different
it's like a flat tire they just keep
pumping air into it okay you get
negative returns okay it still works
but at the cost of doing business or
that kind of business I kind of bail out
ends up being exorbitantly expensive and
it doesn't help Main Street helps Wall
Street and we still haven't gotten away
from that toxic paradigm I would say but
what the mainstream media is saying well
thank God we're not China I think it's
you know thank God we're not
authoritarian I mean this mantra' that
goes on and on for me it's a huge
deflection from what is what is going on
in Western economies okay we can talk
about the Chinese model later okay
misses the point it completely misses
the point of what's going on here go
ahead Nima well like everyone agrees
that the world after this crisis will
change and that it will never be the
same as before so the big question for
me is the the madness of so-called the
expert elite in the West is this madness
going to end after this because what
they have been producing since the
beginning of the crisis was madness you
know first they have been staying for
many years that Russia and China host
donations well now Russia and China send
in medics and equipment to Italy Italy
which has more cases of of death from
coronavirus than China now unfortunately
we are all very very sad about this it's
a tragedy but sorry if Russia and China
had been so evil as the Western experts
had been claiming for years this would
be the right moment to attack basically
because the Western society is in
disarray so the Western society had been
preparing for the fake threats for for
for for decades
and now they are not prepared for the
real threat but what is most disgusting
for me is the fact that the mainstream
American media is trying to use this
tragedy
despite the United States been now
closed third you know behind China and
and Italy they are trying to use it for
political purposes easily the idea is to
get rid of Trump thanks to Corona oh
this kind of criticism is usually it is
a deflection from self-appraisal
self-criticism which later they are
completely incapable Alexander be
curious I mean I was I was I met you and
your wife and a lot more a lot of really
wonderful people little over three weeks
ago and you know and we were talking
over coffee over breakfast over a
wonderful English breakfast you know
that the government doesn't have money
for this the money the government
doesn't have money for that they're
cutting back on this you know and the
Health Service they're worried about and
then now all of a sudden oh they got
tons of money some money to spend on all
kinds of things what happened okay so we
had really the the rhetoric of austerity
up until three weeks ago and now the
floodgates of this I guess virtual money
I mean I really worry that at this point
they have their eye on trying to calm
the situation so much to protect their
own self-interest and the status quo
they're just going to debase the
currency I mean am I wrong well I think
that's right but I think coming perhaps
in what Alex
Christopher Oh said
it does depend a great deal on how long
this situation goes on for we have a
situation where just a few weeks ago we
had a general election in Britain there
were two different programs there was
that which the Conservative government
had and the Labour occur and the Labour
Party and the Labour Party was promising
to spend huge sums of money and that was
supposed to be unaffordable now we have
a situation where the Conservative
government is spending or committing to
spend many orders of magnitude more than
Labour was proposing to spend in the
election and whereas labour you might
disagree profoundly with their policy
but at least it was supposed to be a
program of spending to build the economy
up this is firefighting and not just
firefighting and this is my concern it's
it's money that has been conjured out of
the air because in a situation like the
one we're looking in where there are
problems now in the bond markets
including the British government's own
bond markets they can't it seems to me
be sure of being able to borrow this
money and at the same time we're going
to see a crash in tax revenue because
the economy is closing down so how do
they find the money to fulfill the
commitments that they are now making but
they do seems to be there are these
problems that they really don't know
it's crossed my mind I mean this is good
rhetoric okay it is a point of crisis
particularly if if you've lost your job
in members of your own family you've
lost their jobs on top of it okay I mean
you gotta say something let me go to
alexander Christopher I mean you know
again three weeks ago you know crazy
Bernie where are we gonna get all the
money how could we pay for this and all
of a sudden the money is there I mean
it's really one of the most
extraordinary moments in my potent life
and looking at politics is that you have
someone like Donald Trump in the GOP
that's left to the Liberals and the
Democratic Party on this yeah well I
mean
the difference with Trump and many other
politicians is that Trump has to answer
to his face and his base are the people
you know back in 2008 when when Obama
went through I don't want to say a
similar crisis but a crisis nonetheless
he bailed out Wall Street because Trump
didn't because Obama didn't care about
the people Trump has to answer to the
American people to the heartland to his
base so I think Trump is going to do
whatever it takes to ease their fears
and to help them come through this in
best in the best case scenario that they
can but once again I think the time line
is critical for me the important part is
you need to to shorten out this crisis
as much as possible if this thing drags
on till August September October then
you have a big problem for every country
if they can shorten this out till May or
June then I think we're going to come
out of this okay every country is a
different situation though and people in
Italy are going through a very terrible
terrible time with 800 people almost 800
people died yesterday it's it's a
tragedy of a absolute tragedy and what
hurts me even more but what's also
revealing is that the EU and Brussels
have not done anything that's right for
the Italians nothing and the and the
curtains been drawn for the European
Union's what one last point Peter the
European knows how to have to take money
from banks they know how to impose
austerity they know how to open borders
you know how to tax people they know how
to put v80 they know all these things
but when it comes to a crisis like this
they don't know how to help the average
European citizen it's an absolute
tragedy John Ben Dima go ahead well I've
been reading the Italian press in the
last few days and what they say is very
clear I mean they say we have been
paying to these European Union funds
would have been paying for years and
prob if we save this money for our own
hospitals we would not be in such a
terrible situation now when basically we
have no place to where to put people in
you know when they get infected in the
United States at this moment it's
already too
twenty-five thousand confirmed cases so
it's a real tragedy and it's real
mismanagement in the United States
listen to the radio programs read the
press everyone liberals conservatives
they all agree that our system is
dysfunctional the American health care
system is is serving the interests of
insurance companies but it's absolutely
in fact up to be absolutely irrelevant
when the real house emergency has come
and after this for example in The
Washington Times sorry in the Washington
Post they write the Chinese system I am
quoting Michael Gerson a system built on
fear was based on denial and deception
so our system better talking now I've
heard that before but it has applied
other countries keep going to him again
just just you know the logical of this
and the logic of American liberals or of
the Democratic Party is boring okay
our system failed our service suitable
system was wrong our economic system was
wrong our media was not transparent but
still you must adopt ours and if you
don't adopt it that you are a flat
earther you are a conspiracy theorist
and you should be dealt in the same way
as Qaddafi or Saddam Hussein you know
and they continue doing it I mean read
their again the Washington Post who is
their bad man number one the Mexican
president Lopez Obrador because he said
the truth you know he said a terrible
thing but I am going to quote it from a
Washington Post article it seems to me
for Brad or said that the Americans want
us to get infected at least the American
press that's what they want so they can
blame me for everything and of quote I'm
sorry but taking issue a reaction the
Chad and Floyd from their Western press
when that misfortune
happened in China just ask yourself if
it had been really limited to China what
a flood of devastating articles there
would be in the American press in the
European press just praising the Western
system saying how it was much better you
know so III think real check that recom
highest is the change in ideology okay
that I was hoping that you would say
that because I'm going to go to
Alexander make me curious right now I
mean it seems to me you know it's all
coming back I mean I have been
criticized all of us have been
criticized we're talking about control
of borders can a return of sovereignty
but I mean this is exactly what people
want right now Italy stab at best
example you know they're part of this
great you know holy European Union that
is so morally superior to anything that
has existed in human history but no they
wouldn't even help their own brethren
okay and because of the lack of
sovereignty or limited sovereignty they
probably would have been able to react
in a different way and the same thing
applies as well with the border I mean
the Alexander Christopher I pointed it
out to me earlier is that you know at
least they finally there's a finally and
a reason where you can justifiably say
the border should be controlled because
they don't that's not part of their
ideology that ideology is open borders
and limited if zero sovereignty I mean
this is a game changer when it comes to
talking about politics and talking about
globalization Alexander material
consider Italy what has happened in
Italy is that what we have seen is that
Italy's economy and its government have
been severely weakened because it is
part of a European structure whose
ideology is getting in the way of it
responding or being able to respond in
any effective way so um Alex Christopher
who listed the sort of things that the
European Union does the way it taxes
people the way it is this on open
borders the way it pursues all kinds of
policies that many people have found
indeed a deep media
to get up with but given a crisis like
this it has no answers and the same is
happening in the United States in the
sense that to the extent that they have
answers
they're asking always the wrong
questions so they're focusing on sorting
out problems in the markets even as
their own real economy is imploding
around them or they're insisting on the
principle of maintaining free movement
within the European Union which they
have got go on due to an extraordinary
degree
even as the that policy is causing this
infection to spread through their
populations and it is an ideology makers
ideology is what ultimately affects the
kind of responses that you make to a
crisis of this kind and this ideology
has not only been found short it's also
been found dangerous in a situation like
this because you have weak governments
dysfunctional governments broken down
health systems and people are no clear
chain of control now I just want to add
one little point which is of course
there's been all this talk about the
financial pop markets the two big cities
which are at the center of the world
financial system what is the Western
financial system on New York and London
New York is the city which we hear
there's 10,000 confirmed cases and
apparently the epidemic there is almost
out of control London that beat that
city which you were in just a few three
weeks ago which looks so calm and
peaceful it's the same there's a major
crisis there and instead what we have
seen is their political and
administrative energy has been focusing
not on dealing with the problems on the
ground but in bailing out hedge
funds now if we're gonna continue like
this we are going to have a far worse
crisis than the one though if you know
what the name of that crisis will be
called is it'll be called the pitchfork
and that's exactly where I wanted to go
Alex in Cyprus the financial crisis of
2008 saw the the advent of the Tea Party
movement you saw the advent of the
Bernie Sanders movement maybe not in
name at the time but a left populism and
this is only going this has only been
accelerated to the present because the
quote-unquote the bailouts didn't it
bailed out the wrong people in my
opinion and it allowed people to be
punished in 2008 all the way to the
present that shouldn't have been
punished now we have this it's it's a
nexus now where you have populism on the
right and you have populism on the left
that are blooming gaining strength of
Bernie as an individual couldn't get
across the line but his movement is
still there I feel in this case there's
going to be a lot more demands for
accountability and maybe that's why
Trump is getting ahead of the curve
because talking about deny if you if you
take the government money you take the
government dime you can't do a stock
buybacks I mean in looking at management
to these companies even people on the
right believe it or not over the last
couple of days that have even said a
company like Boeing if you're gonna take
government money the people's money
there should be a board a board member
appointed so they can watch to make sure
that these CEOs and these Board of
Directors put the money where it should
go
I mean maybe boy one day we'll make
planes that fly again okay and we're
gonna bail them out you see what I'm
saying these tendencies on the left and
on the right now they're converging it's
something we didn't see in 2008 go ahead
yeah they're converging but I think the
the center folks of the convergence is
Trump and even though he started out
slow and handling this crisis my own
opinion is that as of late with the
daily press conference this is and the
way he's been taking every question
every question is up ten points on yes I
think he's now showing real leadership
and I think it is the Trump movement not
the Bernie movement that has proven to
be the real movement Birdy's movement in
my opinion with Bernie at the leadership
position has proven to be a complete
fake that's my opinion the Trump
movement though to me is a sovereign
state as a movement it's a movement that
shows globalism does not work let's not
kid ourselves the spread of this virus
and all the things that have gone wrong
leading up to the crisis that we're in
is an effect of this global isn't it's
neoliberal global ISM and I think what
Trump represents and what he tells the
people is yes we can do deals with other
countries yes we can trade but every
country has to look within every country
needs to secure its borders every
country needs to take care of its
citizens every you know I think maybe
naming maybe now we're gonna talk about
healthcare security exactly an every and
eventually and eventually every country
needs to look after its health care for
irritates me when people say they call
me an economic nationalist for wanting
to have health care security that that
is too screwed up okay that this doesn't
make any sense you know we talk about
national security energy security we
have to have health health security as
well here we're rapidly running out of
time go ahead teaming Wow
I agree with Alex because Trump you know
at least the fact that he managed to put
up two trillion dollars to help you know
that to help correct the damage from
this disaster that is a real achievement
but what do we get from the Democrats
you know David Ignatius again in the
Washington Post what we see now is at
hawk podium performance from Trump which
also helped spread disease and
unnecessarily spread disease
unnecessarily I'm quoting what the
Washington Post wrote about civilization
it's the high priests of neoliberalism
in globalism dis orbit audience knows go
ahead emo absolutely so
what I'm concerned about it's obvious
that certain freedoms will have to be
limited now and they had to be limited a
long time ago in that sense China was
the country of the future not the
European Union but again you know I'm
ready to have my freedoms limited when
it's needed for security unfortunately
in the United States and the in the
European Union which freedoms are been
limited now the freedom of opinion okay
well voice please member it's exactly I
do a few days using this format here who
have run out of time gentlemen
fascinating discussion as usual we just
touched the surface here I want to thank
my guests in Cyprus in London and here
in Moscow and thanks to our viewers for
watching us here at RT see you next time
and remember
crosstalk walls
[Music]